MARK MICHANDANI: Teaching
people about cloud architecture
requires some
architecting in itself.
Join us as we talk to Arctiq
about how they build out
dynamic classrooms on this
episode of "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Tim, thanks so much
for joining us.
Tell us a little bit more
about what Arctiq does.
TIM FAIRWEATHER: Yeah,
so thanks for having me.
Arctiq is a services
enablement firm.
And so we focus on
consulting specifically
in the cloud in
the software space,
a heavy focus on automation,
Kubernetes, GCP platform,
and kind of on-ramping
customers and enabling
to do things faster, smoother,
with more efficiency.
MARK MICHANDANI: And
a big part of that
is also helping
them run workshops
for their own forms of training.
TIM FAIRWEATHER: Yeah.
So we're big
believers on enabling.
We're big believers on
come in and show somebody
how to do something,
show someone how to fish.
Right?
Teach someone how to
fish, and they can kind of
be self-sustained.
So the idea is these
workshops enable
us to get our
customers to be very
comfortable with the technology
and get them to touch
the technology that
is ultimately going
to shape how they move forward.
MARK MICHANDANI: So
what's an example
of what a workshop might look
like that an instructor would
put together?
TIM FAIRWEATHER: Yeah, so
an example, a great example,
is out GKE workshops.
And GKE workshops have
been very successful for us
in just getting customers
familiar with all the concepts
inside a GKE, how to get
workloads into there,
and how to manage it,
and day-two operation
sort of stuff.
And ultimately, it turns
out like a shared repository
and a shared project
structure inside of GCP
that houses what we call
our instructor environment.
In that instructor
environment, we
onboard instructors into there.
We onboard them into
our Git repository.
And effectively, they come
prepared with a student list.
And all it takes really
to run a workshop
is a student list and
some students, obviously.
And we get them to build
out a student list,
pass it into Ansible.
Ansible, ultimately, takes care
of the templating function,
taking that student
list, and effectively
building up Terraform plans.
Each student ends up with
their own environment.
So part of our design
goal was making sure
that as students were
onboarded and as we
were running the
workshops, we weren't
running into the traditional
sort of student 4 accidentally
logged into student 1's
environment, as an example,
and you end up with
that collision stuff.
And very much, we
wanted to provide
an experience to our end
users that allowed them
to have their own environment.
If they want to break
it, they break it.
And if they want to test
the boundaries of something
that we don't have
prescribed in a lab,
then we want to enable
them to do that.
We want to enable them to sort
of find the edges on their own
as well.
MARK MICHANDANI: So it's a big
balance between flexibility
and also being able to really
quickly get these things going
up and running.
Sometimes you might have
students that don't show up
or changes that need to
be made, and the system
is designed to
support all of that.
TIM FAIRWEATHER: Yes.
Absolutely.
So part of what we
wanted to do upfront
was give a repeatable
structure for automation,
and a repeatable structure to
offer these workshops in a very
streamlined way, but then
also give the capability so
that if you're running a lab
with us and, all of a sudden,
you tear down your cluster,
which has happened,
and all of a sudden
your GKE cluster's dead.
Ultimately, there's
merit in troubleshooting.
There's merit in kind of
going through the works
of understanding how GKE works
and how to maybe respin up
a new cluster.
At the same time,
it's a workshop,
and we need to sometimes get
to end of job really quickly.
And so it makes more
sense to rebuild your lab.
That whole structure
allows us to target
only your lab resources,
as an example,
and effectively just respin
and let you get on your way.
MARK MICHANDANI: What does an
example student infrastructure
look like?
TIM FAIRWEATHER: Mhm.
Yeah, so the student
infrastructure,
sort of similar
to the instructor
environment in that
there's a GKE cluster
inside of an ephemeral project.
So the real difference
is each and every one
of the student projects is
an ephemeral project itself.
And then we would onboard
each of those students
through the automation
with the right permissions
inside of that project.
So they've got the right
cluster permissions,
all that sort of stuff.
And then, ultimately, inside of
each one of those environments,
they have their own GKE
cluster with Istio enabled
and a bunch of the tooling.
And so we run them
through things
like Cloud Build, and
GCR, and image scanning,
and all that stuff all at the
project level and very much
give them their own customized
and unique environment.
By controlling it all tightly
with the lifecycle management
inside of Terraform
allows us to make sure
that we can spin it up
quickly, modify and manage it
as things break or as
things need to change,
but then also very much
be able to tear it down
with very little effort.
MARK MICHANDANI: So
with the instructors
being able to come in there,
kind of configure everything,
and then having all the
automation come in and complete
that actual running, this is
kind of a naturally volatile
environment.
Right?
You're spinning things up
and spinning things down.
I'm sure this wasn't
just a build it once
and it worked kind of solution.
What would you say, as
you were tweaking it
a long time, especially
the automation portion,
what would you say kind of
the biggest lesson you learned
or the biggest kind of
hurdle you overcame?
TIM FAIRWEATHER: The idea behind
it is we very quickly settled
on Terraform to handle
the actual resource
lifecycle stuff.
The idea of putting
this all in code
and managing it that way was
obviously a very early design
goal.
Part of what we had
tried to do very early on
was use Terraform for taking
that student list in and really
building out the environment.
That way, inside of Terraform
and running things on a loop,
and if we had 20
students, well, that's
20 projects, 20 clusters, and
it should be very repeatable.
So even enabling service
APIs at the project level
becomes a pretty significant
exercise at scale.
It's one thing to
start up a project,
and start up a GKE cluster,
and plumb the various elements.
But we're talking about
doing it 20 times if you've
got a 20-student class.
Ultimately, what
that turned into
is a little bit of a
nightmare around that.
Well, what happens
if somebody's sick,
and they call in before
the workshop starts,
and we need to substitute
person A for person B?
And ultimately, that turned
into a bit of a nightmare
very early on.
And it allowed us--
or it showcased to us that we
really needed to rethink that.
And so I'd say the
biggest learning
lesson was our
integrating Ansible
into the whole scenario.
So not only is the resource
structure and the project
structure very ephemeral,
but the actual Terraform code
itself is very ephemeral.
So that was probably the
biggest thing we learned out
of this whole
thing was sometimes
you've got to pick the
right tool for the job.
MARK MICHANDANI: That
makes a lot of sense.
Thanks so much for
coming in and telling us
a little bit about how you
built this architecture.
TIM FAIRWEATHER: No worries.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MICHANDANI:
Interested in trying out
Terraform for yourself?
Check out the collection
of GCP Terraform examples
to get started.
Thanks for watching, and
make sure to subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]